n'est pas prévu de nouveau référendum
pourquoi d'ailleurs aurait-il lieu
puisque puisque
non mais il n'y a pas de prévu de
nouveaux référendum dans les mois qui
viennent dans les années qui viennent il
faut évidemment que discuter de tout
c'est le principe des discussions mais
la Nouvelle-Calédonie a fait le choix de
la République il y a effectivement
plusieurs questions qui se posent pour
savoir si nous avons la possibilité de
le faire dans le cadre du Parlement
actuel vous avez parfaitement raison le
changement constitutionnel et notamment
je l'ai dit moi-même l'article 77 et son
alinéa 4 me semble-t-il de la
Constitution la question du corps
électoral qui va se poser puisque nous
avons les Provinciales qui sont à
organiser mais il est évident que
l'année de travail qui évoquait le
ministre délégué ne comprend pas un
référendum il comprend le rendu me
semble-t-il des groupes de travail et
nous l'espérons toutes et tous des
bilatérales des trilatérales conclusifs
qui nous permet de faire un chemin et
pourquoi pas monsieur le Président sûr
vous avez parfaitement raison voir
quelles sont les symboles quels sont les
politiques que nous pouvons imaginer
être soit des compétences partagées soit
des compétences entières de la
Nouvelle-Calédonie vous savez d'ailleurs
que c'est l'endroit le plus décentralisé
qui existe dans la République puisque
hormises à faire régaliennes on va pas
très bien ce qu'on pourrait les
centraliser davantage mais nous
pourrions ouvrir des voies et des
chemins c'est-à-dire pour ça que nous
continuons à discuter bien évidemment
l'axe indopacifique évoqué par président
de la République nous montre peut-être
d'ailleurs un de un de ces chemins de
définir ce que nous voulons par une
Nouvelle-Calédonie et quelle est sa
grande place dans la République
française